if you finished horizon forbidden west
but aren't quite sure what was going on
or what the future holds for eloy then
this is the video for you it goes
without saying that we're talking about
forbidden west's ending as well as big
parts of the stories in both forbidden
west and horizon zero dawn so you'll
likely want to complete them before you
continue this video this is going to be
your only warning spoilers ahead
the final mission of horizon forbidden
west sends ailoy and her crew to the
base of the far zeniths a group of
humans from another planet who have
returned to earth the zeniths have
stolen the gaia ai ailoy and her friends
need to stop the extinction of life on
earth their apparent plan is to use gaia
to re-terraform the planet for
themselves in doing that it seems the
far zeniths are willing to let existing
life on the planet get wiped out to make
themselves a little bit more comfortable
the terraforming project might take a
couple hundred years but the far zeniths
don't seem to be in any hurry they're
effectively immortal in fact eloy learns
that the far zeniths are actually a
group of rich people who fled earth in
the 2070s though almost a thousand years
have passed these aren't the descendants
of those rich people but the very same
folks who set up a colony on the
relatively nearby planet of sirius after
leaving earth some disaster destroyed
that colony however and the surviving
farziniths returned to earth with the
plan to take it back and make it their
home they're not interested in sharing
it with the tribal humans who live there
now though aloy comes to believe that it
was the far zeniths who a couple of
decades earlier sent the signal that
kicked off all the problems now facing
the people of earth back in the 2070s an
industrialist named ted farrow created
robots that were basically unkillable
and could consume biomass living things
in other words for fuel when some of
those machines went out of control it
created the pharaoh plague a swarm of
machines bent on destroying everything
on earth the humans of the time realized
they couldn't win the war against the
pharaoh plague led by a scientist named
elizabeth sobek they created the zero
dawn program an ai controlled
terraforming system that would
eventually shut down the faro plague
machines and then reboot the planet
everyone living in the 2070s was doomed
to die but eventually earth and humanity
would go on the plan worked more or less
and we catch up with humanity about a
thousand years later before the start of
horizon zero dawn life on earth was
pretty good thanks to the terraforming
system run by gaia and her subordinate
functions a handful of programs that
each regulate a different major part of
the planet's biosphere suddenly though
gaia received a signal directed at hades
her function built to wipe out life if
something with the terraforming system
should go wrong and gaia needed to start
over the signal gave hades sentience
bringing it to life hades then
immediately tried to kill all life on
earth to stop that from happening gaia
basically blew itself up releasing its
other sub-functions out into the world
the signal was directed at hades but as
a side effect the other sub-functions
gained sentience as well and they went
off and did their own weird things while
hades continued to try to destroy the
planet the story of horizon zero dawn
focuses on eloy learning about and
shutting down hades before it can
reactivate the faro plague in forbidden
west she comes to believe the far
zeniths sent the signal to hades hoping
to activate its extinction protocols
before returning to the planet and
taking it for themselves eloy and her
friends bust into the far zenith base
and take them down with the help of
tilde a far zenith traitor who was
formerly a friend and lover to elizabeth
sobek back in the 2070s the pair broke
up and tilda left the planet while
elizabeth stayed behind to create zero
dawn tilde never really got over it
though and in the climax of the game she
attempts to convince eloy who is a clown
of sobek created by gaia to save the
planet to join her on the far zenith
ship to flee earth together
this is the pivotal bit of information
you need to understand the ending the
zeniths didn't return to earth in hopes
of recolonizing it and they didn't send
the signal to hades in fact they're just
hoping to find or steal a copy of gaia
so they can leave earth aboard their
ship once again they want gaia to
terraform another planet to create a new
colony and they need to do that because
earth isn't safe the zeniths are being
hunted
back on the serious colony as tilde
explains the zeniths attempted to
transcend the immortality of their
bodies to find a way to become digitally
immortal to transfer their
consciousnesses into computers the
experiment failed but attempting it
resulted in a whole host of far zenith
personalities being copied and stored
digitally the game suggests that these
super-rich captains of industry and
invention were largely awful people you
might have guessed that from the fact
that they number one fled earth and left
everyone to die who wasn't rich and two
returned to earth and murdered a bunch
of people indiscriminately the
artificial intelligence they created as
part of their digitalization experiment
wasn't deleted but was instead abandoned
mixed together with all the
personalities of these terrible
megalomaniacs that was effectively
torture and somewhere along the way that
tortured program became self-aware and
grew to hate its creators the farzeniths
called the ai they made
nemesis
nemesis hated humanity so much that as
soon as it gained awareness it started
attacking the serious colony the colony
was ravaged in a matter of hours killing
almost everyone who lived there except
for a handful of people who were lucky
enough to jump in their spaceship and
escape but the far zeniths had basically
nothing with them except what was aboard
the ship and they had nowhere to go so
they headed back toward earth when the
far zeniths escaped nemesis figured
they'd probably head home it was nemesis
that sent the signal to wake up hades
hoping to make earth uninhabitable
before the zeniths could even arrive
when that failed however nemesis headed
into space to follow the zeniths on
their trek to earth the zenith's plan
was to gain control of gaia and head out
in a random direction hoping to give
nemesis a slip find a new home and
terraform it they knew earth would be
destroyed when nemesis arrived but they
didn't care much not that there was a
whole lot they could seemingly do about
it tilde tries to force aeloy to leave
earth with her using the specter prime
machine but aloy fights back and tilde
is killed afterward silence shows up and
confirms that he knew about nemesis
while eloy was involved in the events of
the frozen wilds horizon zero dawn's dlc
add-on silence captured and tortured
hades to learn more from it that
interrogation taught him about the far
zeniths and nemesis silence then made a
plan to fight the far zeniths and use
their ship to escape earth himself it
was silence that helped regala with her
rebellion and taught her and her people
how to override machines in exchange for
his assistance regala agreed that she
and her tanakh rebels would help silence
fight the zeniths with the zeniths all
dead silence invites ailoy to join him
on the far zenith ship but she turns him
down instead intending to stay behind
and fight to save the planet silence 2
eventually decides to stay behind and
help at least for a while he's inspired
by aloy's selflessness it seems but then
again silence always seems to have a
scheme in the works and his motivations
are tough to guess it seems like he
wants to help but who knows if he has
some secret self-serving plan
finally eloy dispatches her friends to
head back to their respective tribes to
ask for assistance against nemesis at
this point eloy is a respected warrior
she saved the karja in meridian helped
the tanakh fight off regala's rebellion
worked to keep the uttaru from starving
and provided helpful data to the queen
pretty much everyone in the known world
owes eloy a favor and her work
throughout forbidden west should have
engendered enough goodwill that they'll
help her fight the approaching threat
what we don't know however is what that
threat actually is nemesis is some kind
of ai but apart from that we know
nothing about it or its capabilities
like hades it seems nemesis is bent on
extinction of all life on earth but we
don't know what it might do to achieve
that goal there are other loose threads
still hanging as well gaia has retrieved
some subordinate functions but it lost
hephaestus the function responsible for
creating and deploying robot animals to
actually run the terraforming system
hephaestus is the reason the world is
full of hostile machines it gains
sentience when hades did and like hades
it doesn't particularly like people
without hephaestus the threat of earth's
biosphere failing and life becoming
extinct remains a very real one gaia can
stave off extinction for a bit but she
can't control the full power of the
terraforming system without hephaestus
and its machines there's also apollo the
gaia function that was also a giant
database of all human knowledge apollo
was created as part of the zero dawn
program back in the 2070s before the end
of the world but the database was
destroyed by ted farrow because he was a
massive prick
because he was a massive pile of living
garbage
without apollo the humans born after
gaia terraformed the planet were forced
to fend for themselves without the
knowledge of the civilization that came
before them that's why nobody in eloy
society really understands all the
technology around them and why they've
created a new tribalistic civilization
apollo still exists however aboard the
far zenith ship during the forbidden
west end game gaia is in the process of
assimilating apollo back into her system
but first has to clean it of any
potentially malicious far zenith code
who knows how long that process could
take but the fact that eloy and her
people might soon have access to apollo
is potentially huge that will almost
definitely be a society altering
development that will have social and
political repercussions for everybody to
say nothing of the fact that locating a
knowledge repository like apollo has
been silen's overarching goal all along
it also seems fully possible that some
unexpected far zenith problem with
apollo could crop up in the future too
so the world is about to change
drastically at the end of horizon
forbidden west gaia is trying to save
the biosphere and hunt down hephaestus
while ailoy is gathering allies to mount
a defense against nemesis a huge amount
of knowledge is about to enter aloy
society whether people are ready for it
or not and there's another world-ending
threat just beyond the
horizon hopefully we won't have to wait
another five years to see what happens
next for more on horizon including early
game tips combat tips as well as our
review stick around on gamespot and
thanks for watching
[Music]
you